it was shortly after 5 a.m sunday when
two men entered this ottawa apartment
building and started a fire terrifying
actions captured on surveillance cameras
residents say it happened about an hour
after they confronted protesters
verbally about noise outside the
building i was up between three and five
from the sounds of the honking i
couldn't sleep like many other residents
this woman says she's afraid to be
identified in case she's singled out and
targeted matthias munoz is an exception
this is a perfect example of
the situation that can arise when this
kind of like lawlessness happens even
more shocking is this section of the
surveillance video there is evidence of
somebody taping our door shut
so somebody came in tried to light a
fire and basically lock all of us in
here allegations that someone tried to
start a fire in this building lobby are
driving a new edge between residents and
the protesters and nerves are wearing
thin did you just like wake up and find
the first person with a flag and try and
blame them for everything i'm blaming
the culture and the environment so it's
my fault that that
you're participating in has created one
of constant harassment intimidation and
threats both men in this exchange
declined to be interviewed we're
concealing the identity of residents who
say they're afraid their homes have
become targets this is really the
scariest day that i've i've had
here
or ever
global news spoke to a woman who
encountered the men in the lobby she
says one of them told her i'm a
protester i support the protest as the
ottawa police arson unit investigates
some residents say they're so shaken
they've decided to sleep elsewhere they
say the lobby could easily have caught
fire leading to loss of life there's a
lot of well-meaning people out there
trying to fight for what they believe in
i don't agree with it but there are bad
actors that come out of the woodwork in
these kind of situations while sleep has
been in short supply for the last 11
days residents hope for peace in coming
days as they await an outcome
ross lord global news ottawa